you know what i would like to hear what
right now stunner man's got big stepping
big stepping
everyone's doing the big stepping
pillow on the remix
look at that wow dude can we make that
happen bro bro
are you are you like uh what
is it happening bro you're the [ __ ]
police i'm just telling you what i want
to hear bro you're the [ __ ] police
jesus christ jesus christ jesus christ
bro why bro why are you like that what
do you mean about your
bro
he has a wiretap
he's tapping the phones well i feel like
this you're a big niner guy this guy's
tapping the phone you're a big niner guy
this is like the niner anthem yes this
is it yeah one thousand percent shout
out to stutter man
we're still with it even mixing from the
bengals is hitting the big step in there
come on scores it makes it from the bay
man yeah that makes sense come on man
you know shout out to joe mitchell
that's that's the family so you're gonna
be on the remix
who knows bro well then why would i be
referred to as the feds for bringing up
who knows bro who [ __ ] knows wow
who knows bro
big step in remix who knows well maybe
get the gang back together for oh no
bro this guy is crazy bro
well bay area a little love like little
barry remix what wow this guy this guy
does it man this guy you see all these
plaques
is it coming out